[Musik]
davon ist natürlich noch mal draußen
regnet ja eigentlich abhängig gehört die
kinos locken
hier klingt ich bin zurück meine damen
und herren die kamera wohl kontrolliert
560 euro an dieser stelle eine ganz
kleine brust an polizist ihr was mir
garantie ist aber freunde immer als
positiv dem eine kamera wie der heide
meine lieblings 1000 der verdammten
wäsche verpächters abholen werde wenn
ich mit möglichen käufern oder wenn ich
mir eine neue liebe gesprochen ich werde
mir jetzt noch immer würden die gefahren
und danach habe ich einen termin
beträchtlich
aber es war ja schon auf mein blog das
passiert irgendwie lief wirklich war
sony hat meine mikrofon halter abgemacht
ich hatte hier oben auf die mikrofone
eigentlich immer so ein bisschen plüsch
drauf damit dass bei windgeräusche
niklas ist hier sieht man nur noch ein
bisschen tesafilm abstehen
freunde dafür benötigen wir erstmal die
vision kamera reparieren wenn ich gerade
von der kamera die pakete geschickt
werde habe ich noch immer sieben minuten
wirklich marco motta 70
aber noch nie war die partnerwahl lecker
essen von vier tage ich war jetzt gerade
markt und ich bin eine halbe stunde
zwischen ich höre euch dass ihr das
erste was er sagen wird dabei für mich
von einer halben stunde darin
[Musik]
rintanen
bringing artikel autokultur kuckuck kgk
hinzusetzen
das wohlgemerkt fünf minuten später das
klever fahrscheine
ich weiß nach hause weil ich habe mir
hier hinten neue jetta gekauft dann
packt er schnell meine wohnung kamera
aufgestellt damit machen kann von wegen
ich komme an und stelle pakete dahin
aber sind die pakete dann jedoch leider
umgefallen und durch dieses umfallen
durch die laute geräusch eine
reinigungskraft darauf aufmerksam
geworden dass ich wieder in der wohnung
bin also die uk könnte vielleicht da am
dienstag um kommen und dann irgendwie
wohnung reinigen
gegen 14 uhr und die antwort einfach
nicht
nachteil gerade kommt nach hause lagert
in sachen hier kein als zu hause und die
uns einfach da kann man nichts machen
auf jeden fall vertraulich
ja
wir haben einfach gerade mitten auf der
straße geparkt alles klar mir einzig auf
naomi campbells das model habe seine
termine sind für heute eigentlich
erstmal erledigt ich war music download
merkte ich habe ein paar sachen für die
uni noch erledigt zwischendurch und
jetzt bei audi welchen ich schwöre ich
am ersten tag wird pro geil aber einen
block arbeitet darf das ganze jetzt
eventuell leichter wind anhört und ihr
natürlich auch alle dummheit und so ich
schlau
[Musik]
also jetzt gerade durch die blockierer
aufnehme ist der dienstag dann werde ich
jetzt auch noch den mittwoch gleich
aufnehmen dabei der dann gleich im video
sehen und das heißt video kommt dann am
donnerstag wenn das video hier dann
allerdings am donnerstag hochgeladen
wird formieren beschnitten wird der blog
von diesen beiden tagen von dem dienstag
und mittwoch nämlich am donnerstag und
am freitag schon wieder auf das nächste
blog über den donnerstag in den freitag
kommt an die rambla da nehme ich
allerdings auch schon den samstag und
den sonntag auf der nächste block und
dementsprechend am montag dann nehme ich
aber auch schon den montag und dienstag
auf das kommt dann am mittwoch mit
donnerstag kommt am freitag weiter krank
wiederaufnahme kommt am sonntag und lege
schon das jeden zweiten tag etwa den
blog kommen allerdings nicht jeden tag
weil ich halt nicht jeden tag den block
aus hochadel wiener zwei tage in einem
blog dementsprechend die vergangene
woche sind einfach nicht den stress aber
jeden tag im video zu schneiden
weil die krankheit video gewinnen ich
versuche mit
mehrere zu tun und ist gefährlich
gemacht und war dann halt ihren zweiten
tag die die und profanen wasserpfeifen
mit den länger hätten anstatt jeden tag
ein kostenblock und jetzt werden sich
wahrscheinlich noch einige von euch
fragen hey wenn du gewinnen willst wenn
man die challenge machen bild weder mein
training oder großfamilie clever
marginal vor keine ahnung war das wird
als party in die block 1 aufhalten kann
weil das ich mal mein tagwerk vorbei im
video natürlich den zweiten tag bemerkte
irgendwie nichts passiert dann
wirklichkeit einfach sagen okay nicht
klar dass wir nicht viele banker noch
eine runde klar oder so damit der
blogger mehr oder weniger einfachen
inhalt
wer sich heute für schönefeld
angestellten hat einmal haben wir hier
checken panini entweder eine friedliche
hoyer fdp hat hier die nudeln sind in
der fakultät altes interplay kaputt
filter funktioniert nicht mehr richtig
neue interface die neue mutter bei mir
in der wohnung
das ist allerdings schon neun uhr ist
werde ich jetzt mit max trainieren geben
ein sommer eigentlich so beschissen
deine ruhe gerechnet ich habe gerade man
sich anfühlt mit meinem neuen tischen
gespielt wird irgendwie zwei oder drei
uhr nachts auf jeden fall schlafen und
dann sehen wir uns morgen früh wieder
[Musik]
weiter tag in diesem blog ist gerade 40
und bestellung geht mit bugs trainieren
aber vorher wird mein kleiner kaktus
wege gibt mir die armee liege bedenkt
dass ich mich sehr kleine würde cool
versicherungen dass mein vater ist
unfähig ich habe hier extra das fenster
aufgemacht und jetzt liegt eine fliege
ein bisschen verrücken und wollte ich
glaube ich fliege ich dir etwas essen
und wenn ich vielleicht wieder komme und
wie immer noch liegt dann hast du deine
chance verspielt da der s3 und befragen
ich bin wieder unten angekommen
froidevaux mein gott bist du unfähig
alter
ich habe gerade eine fliege geräten eine
dame nachlassen müssen immer so spät
alter
klima an strenge gesetzliche schnell und
wohl machbar vereinsvermögen jährlich an
brücken über zehn kilometer breit
[Musik]
berlin
profikampf solchen tag mit danke ohne
dass wir das gar nicht richtig gesteuert
ihr stehen jetzt wie man es natürlich
macht im ikea verstecken und
jugendlichen versteckt ist es nach
kurzen für die kurzen angeht dürfte ihn
als auch direkt etwas halt nicht viel
kurz und warten eben auch
[Musik]
und super spieler damit verstecken nicht
existente orakel später markt wieder
damit verstecken dass es nicht geben
inhalt eigentlich gar nicht ich muss
marktplatz besuchen also viel krampf
gekauft 14 bilderrahmen und alles also
das jetzt marktplatz ich weiß nicht wo
der jetzt fordert eskaliert und für
unten noch größer die firma
währungsreform kümmert wird auf jeden
fall machen die wir alle eingekauft
haben und wir sehen uns jetzt im auto
wieder
ich habe mir was gekauft ich weiß nicht
mehr genau wo ich gewinnen aber es kann
sein dass es schon andere youtuber
gerade gemacht oder durch bemächtigt
sich jetzt klar dass der erste beide
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich ob hey
hey was ist das denn dass der partie
übermorgen blog also ich zeigt morgen
also am morgigen tag aber der block
kommt dementsprechend übermorgen weil
ich ja immer nur zwei tage film und dann
immer hochladen einer freundin im auto
und liest und luca einkaufen waren der
kol
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt mein video geschnitten
hochgeladen ich habe wieder frei als
nächstes werde ich jetzt die gegangen
sachen die ich mir mit max geholt habe
alle auf packungen und gegen eine wand
hängen und 2000 sofort wie wandel
reagieren und dafür so voll wie
bilderrahmen und hätten uns noch klar
ist gekauft also müssen was verändern
sollen an einer bude dauern jetzt
wahrscheinlich allerdings zwei drei
stunden
im block total verwerten der freizeit
dan blocker seit jahren meine damen und
herren wir bewerten die merck positive
sache dass wir uns schon viel
aufgeräumter austria viele haben schon
aufgebaut
viele sachen wetter freuen erhöht und
banker räumt relativ viel schlechte
wartet allerdings dass ihr weg stunden
vergangen sind ist gerade ganz genau 28
also hat gerade halt jähriger verließ
möglich von dem her aufgebaut und mit
meinem sport neu aufgenommen linke durch
reibung meine damen und herren gerne
auftreten ich werde jetzt allerdings
verschlafen in welchem fach hundemüde
bin ich hoffe euch gefällt dieses neue
format sag ich mal das nicht mal zwei
tage blöcke und lastern halbhoch lade
ich glaube das hat jetzt eigentlicher
verstandes morgen kommt kein video aber
übermorgen wieder brach von morgen und
übermorgen und ich würde sagen die
schlappen guten abschluss
[Musik]